have you ever wondered why you're tired
all the time or more likely have you
ever started any training program and
just been far too tired to work out when
the time comes and this extends to other
areas of your life as well maybe you
don't have the energy to do the dishes
at night maybe you wanted to start a new
business or learn a new skill and you
just don't have enough energy to do that
either you just come home and you want
to crash out on the sofa and play Sonic
the Hedgehog over and over again because
it's the best game in the world I'm not
talking about myself here I'm talking
about someone I know I can totally
relate to this day I'm a new parent so
I'm tired all the time I don't know if
I've mentioned that before on this
channel any like maybe a million times
every single opportunity I get point is
lots of us are tired all the time
there are countless different programs
supplements diets and fads out there
that claim to help the only issue is
that none of them really work and even
if they do the change is normally
extremely minor why I'm about to tell
you might seem really obvious to you or
if you're anything like me it might come
as a bit of a revelation when you
realize it for the first time and that
is the single thing that causes most of
us to feel tired is stress and also
doing too much we look at all these
different possible explanations maybe I
need to improve my sleep maybe I need to
take this special supplement maybe I'm
not exercising enough maybe I'm
exercising too much when actually
they're probably just doing too much
stuff and we're too stressed and so we
have no energy to do anything else that
we actually want to do
we're overworked we've burned out the
problem is we slave away at work we've
got a long commute there and back we try
and do all these chores when we come
home we've got social commitments we've
got debt all these other things we're
trying to cram all that in and then on
top of that we're trying to work out as
well and then we wonder why we don't
have energy for it the thing is you need
that recharge time it's not something in
just opt to skip out on you need to
refuel the tank too much exercise too
much activity that won't leave you
mentally exhausted you'll still be able
to come home and read a big book or
start a new project and at the same time
you can also adapt to that kind of
activity emotional tiredness though and
stress that's a whole different kettle
of fish when you spend all day arguing
with people on the phone or being told
what to do or biting your tongue that's
proper exhaustion when you get
home you just won't have the energy or
the inclination to train earthly
whatever else it is that you want to do
from a biological perspective being in a
state of chronic stress means that
you're constantly producing cortisol and
adrenaline you're spending all your time
in a catabolic state burning through
your fuel reserves burning through your
tissue causing a buildup of adenosine
and other byproducts in your brain and
throughout your body eventually get to
the point of adrenal fatigue where your
adrenal glands are just like I'm done
I've got no more adrenaline at that
point you're exhausted of course you're
not gonna be training or starting
anything significant new this is the
point of burnout effectively it's the
same thing as overtraining or
overreaching it's even be referred to as
twenty-first-century syndrome because
it's so prevalent today so if you want
to make a change to your fitness or your
self-development don't start by trying
to add something new start by trying to
take something away you can't just keep
adding more and more commitments and
expect your body and your brain to just
keep up if you want to start a new
training program look at other things
that can cut out look at ways that you
can make your work less stressful maybe
you can remove your commute somehow by
doing a job share or bike using flexi
time or working from home maybe you talk
to your manager because you've got too
much on your plate
maybe you remove some of your social
commitments or your after school
curriculum maybe you hire a cleaner or a
chef or you just find some way to cut
back on all the stuff you're doing so
that you've then got a slot for the new
training program if you're really
committed to getting into shape and
making that kind of change then you need
to cut back on something some people
will say well I can't work less because
my work is so important and I have a
family to support and things well that
might be true and very commendable but
remember that your fitness and your
health are super important as well as
are your happiness and actually maybe
you've got your priorities a bit wrong
if you're working so hard
you've got no energy to do the other
things you want to do in the evening
finally when training or when starting a
new project make sure it's something
you're really excited about because as
we've seen energy comes a lot of the
time from emotion if you're really
pumped for something really psyched
you'll produce hormones but help to
override tiredness so find a way to
train that you enjoy whether that means
starting martial arts or doing a sport
or doing bodyweight training or lifting
heavy weights
remove the bits you're not looking
forward to like the commute to the gym
perhaps or maybe find a training buddy
who you look forward to training with or
treat yourself to a great meal
afterwards whatever the case you should
be replacing something that's draining
with something you can't wait to do the
result is he'll have more energy will
likely stick to your programs and you'll
create more positive change you can then
build off of in the future first just a
little quick tip I hope you found it
useful and interesting if you did then
please leave a like and share around
comment down below and let me know if
this applies to you and stay tuned
because I've got lots more content like
this on the way on fitness brain
training bodybuilding all that cool
stuff if that sounds good
then thanks ton for watching and bye for
now